eu leaders meet tonight to discuss
uh new sanctions against belarus after
authorities in
minsk forced a ryan airplane to land
and arrested a passenger on board exiled
belarusian activist
roman protestevic was traveling from
greece to lithuania
when the aircraft was diverted to
belarus escorted by a fighter jet under
the pretense of a security alert
the incident has sparked global outrage
with western leaders describing it as a
hijacking and
aviation piracy ireland and ryanair say
security agents were on flight
and left it after it touched down in
minsk belarus
rejects the accusations as unfounded
the crowd at vilnius airport waiting for
hours
for a plane that finally arrived
without roman protozovich on board a
message from the regime in belarus
critics aren't safe anywhere even in the
air
i am we are roman protozovich solidarity
for the blogger and activist who now
faces up to 15 years in prison
pratosovich was living in exile he's a
co-founder of nichta
an activist channel on the telegram
messaging app used to help organize
protests against the belarusian
government
on sunday the ryanair flight he was on
had almost reached vilnius
when it was forced to make a u-turn and
head with military escort seen here
to minsk passengers described an
hours-long ordeal on the ground that
started off with belarusian police
taking protozovic into custody they just
came
and they
first of all they took the i think they
took the
the guy the journalist out from the
plane
and then they started disembarking the
passengers
european and u.s diplomats quickly
condemned the arrest as well as the
diversion of the plane
eu commission president ursula fonda
lyon tweeted the outrageous and illegal
behavior of the regime in belarus will
have consequences
she continued those responsible for the
ryanair hijacking must be sanctioned
protozoa's nista colleagues have also
called for sanctions
international pressure should be
increased the protests will not help
people cannot fight guns with stones
there should be economic pressure
a boycott of the regime european
politicians should finally
ask what would be effective
european leaders are discussing
suspending transport links between
belarus and the eu
as well as suspending belarusian
overflights
other sanctions are in the works an
effort to make the regime pay
for its defiance of international and
human rights law
let's get the latest from the belarusian
capital journalist hannah lubiakova
joins us from minsk
welcome to dw and what has been heard of
roman
protozovich since he left the plane
so what we know now uh we do not know
know much to be honest but he
is being held at the kgb prison most
probably
there is no information about him there
and the lawyer cannot reach him
the lawyer is not allowed to to meet him
and talk to his defendant so we do not
know what's happening behind
the walls of the prison um there are
currently
three criminal cases that were launched
against roman bandarenko in belarus
um we do not know whether his kind of
the fact that he was on the kgb
terrorist list was
anyhow um qualified for any terrorist
accusations against him
so this is not known yet um
and basically the the authorities in
belarus are kind of
silent about the situation with rahman
because i think
the situation kind of the effect of his
arrest
was something that they did not expect
and now they're trying to
to kind of hide silence this information
right uh the state media there in
belarus reporting that the kidnap order
came from the president himself
why is this one 26 year old so important
to him
well indeed lukashenko said that he
himself ordered to
kind of race a fighter jet to escort the
plane to the airport in minsk
rahman bandarenka
by the kgb since november last year
he's a prominent journalist he's a
prominent blogger he's been very
active on social media and he has helped
to spread information about
the protests about police brutality
about the situation in the country
via this influential telegram channel
called
nexta and that's kind of the most
important telegram channel in the
country and was
crucial it was basically a key
um played a key role during the protest
in august when there was no internet at
all
and telegram was only partly accessible
so uh everybody knows about rahman
pradeshivish and bowarus and he
um he has been a prominent journalist
and and kind of people are really
concerned about
his safety at the moment and what's
happening with him right now
thank you for that uh thanks for joining
us journalist hannah lubiakova
in minsk
let's get more on the eu reaction to
this incident from dw's at brussels
bureau chief alexandra fun norman
welcome
alexandra so the eu leaders meeting
tonight
to discuss the bloc's reaction um what's
on the table
an array of potential punitive measures
that is what's on the table some member
states
such as lithuania or poland are saying
that it's what's needed is a non-fly
zone over belarus
they are calling on suspending all
european union flights
over belarus airspace they are also in
favor of
banning the belarusian state-owned
airline from
landing at european union airport
and france has always come come forward
with
a sort of proposal to also discuss
suspending all traffic including
ground transit uh from belarus
to the european union something that
would have a major effect on the the
country's economy
and we will see what they are able to
decide
but that's it's totally visible that
they are
under a lot of pressure to act after
they have chosen a very strong language
to condemn
the incident in minsk so does that
pressure mean that we are likely to see
a unified reaction
well the decision today will definitely
be another
test for the blocks foreign policy that
was struggling in the past last week
the european union wanted to speak with
one voice
and to release a statement on the
israel gaza a crisis that was not
possible because hungary blocked that
statement
hungary blocked also a declaration
condemning china for its security law
in hong kong so as you can see it's
been difficult for the european union to
to find to speak with one voice
so we will see if hungary and victor
orban
is considered a strong ally of vladimir
putin
will be on board but we at least can
can expect a statement released by the
majority
of member states okay let's talk then
about uh the influence of russia behind
this we'll hear now from the ceo of
ryanair that's uh this is michael
o'leary who says that they were security
agents
on the flight this was a case of
state-sponsored
uh it was a state-sponsored hijacker
state-sponsored piracy
i think it was very frightening for the
crew for the passengers and who were
held under armed guard had their bags
searched
um when it was clear it appears that the
intent of the russian authorities was to
remove a journalist and his traveling
companion
and you know we believe there was also
some uh kgb
agents off loaded off the aircraft as
well
alexander the presumption is that
president luka shankar wouldn't have
taken such a dramatic step without it
being signed off by the kremlin
so is this likely to affect the already
fraught relations between the eu and
russia
well that is something that we can
really assume i mean russia was the
reason for
eu leaders to come together and have the
dinner tonight in the first place to
discuss the relations with russia
that are being described as being at the
lowest
level uh in in decades even according to
your foreign policy chief
however there are always member states
arguing that it's important
to to try to work together with russia
because
the european union needs russia to solve
international crisis for example so uh
we'll see if they can have a common
position
on that what is clear is this that this
operation in minsk uh
could not happen without the support of
russia its secret service and
it's also clear that alexander
lukashenko could not
be able to hold on to power for such a
long time without vladimir putin's
support
okay thank you for that alexandra von
nerman in brussels
you